the million-dollar question that every
developer has to ask themselves is where
do I put my break points defining break
points based on specific devices
products brand names or anything else
will almost always result in a
maintenance nightmare you never know
what next hot device will be or what
will be hot two years from now instead
look at the content to find the right
break points Scott yells said it best we
shouldn't choose break points at all
instead we should find them using our
content as a guide Pete I would love to
get some insight into the choices that
you make when you're trying to decide
what break points to use on a page sure
let's take a look